Hello everybody. How's everyone doing?
Thanks for attending our workshop. So,
my name is Nolan. Uh, I lead a lot of
our product efforts in Google Cloud
around Web 3. Um, we've been building
web 3 products and services since 2018,
believe it or not, starting with
BigQuery data sets. Um, and we'll walk
you through a few of the things that
we're building, but we have data sets
for over 40 different blockchains. We
have faucets for a bunch of different
test networks. Um and uh yeah, we're
building a lot of agentic access to
these things as well. Um but one of the
things we're really focused on is
agents, agentic payments, and one of the
big things is the is trust between
agents. We think that's a big gap. So
we'll get into that. I also have Gotham
here.
>> Hello. Hello everyone. Uh my name is
Gotham. I work on the engineering side
for the Google Web 3 uh team. uh we
helped support a lot of different ser
offings offerings like bigquery faucets
and uh we're excited to talk to you
about ERC 80004 which is a really
exciting um ERC especially in this space
of gentic commerce and the future of it.
So the the way we're going to structure
this today is we'll talk about the
product like why trust matters among
agents um how 80004 is really a great
solution for trust um and then how you
can get access to that 80004 data using
BigQuery because we have all of the
Ethereum data from Genesis to the ch tip
of the chain indexed in BigQuery. Um and
then we'll walk you through some live
like SQL queries and how you can pull
that data out. Um, and we'll talk about
like what a winning application might
look like. So, we're offering $5,000
cash prize to to to the winner. Um, so,
you know, like right now there's agents
are doing more and more, right? They're
we're giving them more autonomy. They're
able to now purchase and interact with
other agents. Um, but it's really hard
to give more and more trust or autonomy
to these agents unless you know like who
you're dealing with, right? If agents I
I don't know about you guys, but I
envision a world where agents are going
to delegate to agents that are going to
delegate to more agents, right? And real
time markets are going to be created on
the fly, these kinds of things. In that
world, it's important to know who you're
working with or at least have some idea
of the reputation around this um agent.
Um and we have a lot of different uh
standards and protocols that have come
about like MCP obviously everyone's
using MCP to talk to different tools and
services. We have A toa A. So Google
worked on an agent to agent protocol
which standardizes communication between
agents. Um but one of the things that's
still missing is uh is this like trust
piece here, right? And just give me one
second here. I'm actually on the wrong
slide deck. So I'm just going to back up
here for a minute. Um if you want to
take me off for a second,
um I apologize. Give me a second here.
It's going to look very different, but
it's going to be awesome.
All right.
Um, yeah, we can get started again. All
right.
Dark mode for everybody. All right. Um,
so as I was talking about like we have
different ways of communicating between
uh agents and services and agents and
agents. So, we know like how to do that,
but how do you actually trust an agent
across organizational boundaries, right?
If your agent's going to hire something
else within your organization, this
isn't a problem. Your agents can talk to
other agents, you trust them inherently.
But if you're going to go to third party
agents, you actually need an answer for
this, right? And so 804 bridges that gap
by establishing three different pieces
here. So, identity, who is this agent,
right? So uh we'll dive deep into these
but basically it's issuing an NFT to the
agent um which then you can um verify
with uh reputation. So allowing anybody
to leave feedback on a different on an
agent and its quality and score it. And
then validation. And this is still a
work in progress, but how do you prove
that the agent did the work that it says
it's going to do or at least um have
like a a ZK proof or some verifiable way
to know like the usage of this agent
over time, right? And we built this 804
standard with uh a collaboration between
MetaMask, Ethereum Foundation, and
Coinbase. Um and it's been live on the
Ethereum mainet since Jan 29. And it's
on a bunch of other chains. And if you
go to the GitHub repo, you can see all
of the different chains that it's uh
live on. Um so the first part of this is
identity, right? Um how do you manage
that? So uh we have uh a mechanism here
where you call uh a register event on
this smart contract. And when you do
that, you basically submit some key
pieces of data about your agent, which
I'll walk through on the second slide
here. Um, and what happens in the
background is an NFT gets minted, it
gets associated with your agent, and you
get an agent ID. Um, and then you're
able to use that ID going forward um, to
prove who you are. Um, obviously you can
hold the NFT. So only the wallet that
that called this register event um, will
hold that NFT and it'll prove that it's
the owner of this agent. Um so if we
look a little bit more deeply into like
what that file looks like is it's a name
a description and then the most
important part are these services right
so it's like the endpoints with which
you access this agent um so it could be
your ADA endpoint if you have like an
MCP server on top of it could be that um
you're also able to um mark whether this
supports X42 um whether it's active and
then like what trust models it supports
reputation being the primary one. Um,
this registrations field is actually
something that happens post registration
and it updates the the the agent URI.
Um, but you don't submit with that. You
submit with all these other pieces. Um,
and you get you get back an agent ID and
a global identifier from the registry.
Um, so that's the first part and
establishing an identity. The second
part is reputation, right? So there's a
contract method called give feedback
where you pass in an agent ID um a a
pairing of values and and the decimal
places and then tags. Um so this is
meant to be open-ended right now because
it's still very early. We felt like it
didn't make sense to be very
prescriptive about which tags to
support. Um but you know like we for by
for example you can do things like a
star rating, the uptime rating, response
times, things like that. Um, and now
when you give a feedback with an to an
agent that you've been working with,
other people are able to look at that
because it's onchain and it's public.
So, it's some construct for establishing
a reputational system for your agents.
Um, and we'll have we'll leave a lot of
time at the end of this for questions
and answers um, if you have any. Um, so
that's the second part. The third part
is still very much being worked on, but
the idea is that uh you could request a
proof or validate that this agent by
giving in an ID um an URI and like a
validator and a hash that this agent did
the work that it said it was going to
do, right? So, uh a third party
validator would prove that. Um and
there's different ways you can score
that. And so this is still being worked
on. This is not really part of the spec.
There's no registry for this yet. Um, if
you have ideas, I think that would be a
cool thing to work on, although it's not
really part of the um, bounty, if you
will. Um, but it's it's something that
um, needs work and that we're looking
for collaborators on. So, um, if you
have strong ideas about how to do this
proof proof of work, um, let us know.
Um, these are the different smart
contracts on the Ethereum mainet for the
identity registry and the reputation
registry. They're two different smart
contracts. um that you can look at and
from our prize page, this is all linked
um as well as the sample queries that
we're going to go through in a second
here. Um and so what we have um
available for you guys to use is our
BigQuery Ethereum data set, right? So
this is from Genesis to the tip of the
chain uh available to you. Um it's as a
public good. It's not free per se, but
we do have a generous free tier of 1
TBTE um a month. Um, and anybody who's
uh entering this track will issue a
$1,000 coupon to build over the course
of this weekend. It'll actually extend,
I think, for a few weeks past that,
maybe for a month. Uh, you can check
with us at the booth and I can give you
an exact time frame. Um, but we don't
want you to spend a lot of money,
obviously, building for the hackathon.
So, we're giving you a $1,000 coupon.
Um, you probably don't even need to use
a lot of that, frankly, because we give
you a terabyte for free. Um, and that
should be sufficient for a lot of this.
But, um, we have the full Ethereum, uh,
you know, all of the data. You're only
going to be looking at a subset of it
for this purposes of this hackathon. If
you enter this track, um, which is the
804 data, which is why we listed these
um, smart contracts. Um, to I'll go
really quick on how to do this because
it's not always obvious. You have you do
have to set up a Google Cloud um, ID or
account. Um, it does require a billing
ID. Um, so you have to associate it with
some form of payment, but we're going to
give you a coupon that you'll add by
going to this URL. Um, and then you can
go to our web3 portal and find our
Ethereum data set. Um, and then from
there you can open up BigQuery Studio
and start querying. And Gotham's going
to show you how to do that in just a few
minutes here. Um, but we'll make it we
made it pretty easy to get access to
this 804 data. Um, so yeah, do you want
to take it away?
>> Uh, sure. Yeah. Yeah. Thanks, Dalan. Um
so we have a couple queries here to kind
of demonstrate. Um and Nolan if if it's
possible we it might be good to um show
it on BigQuery, right? So um if you guys
go to the the the prize card, there's
actually a link to the BigQuery product
>> and if we go there
>> Oh, let's go to the Yeah, let's go to
the card. Yep.
>> And if you scroll down to the bottom,
you should see a link for Yep. BigQuery
Ethereum data set. So this kind of shows
the documentation of like what these
fields are. So we're going to go to
Ethereum mainet.
>> Yep. Click on data set.
>> These are internal URLs. Don't worry
about those. Yours will say
console.cloud.google.com.
>> And these are the different tables
available to you.
>> Yep. And if you want to know what the
fields are, if you go up to the
supported data sets, uh the middle tab,
middle tab, uh like high like the tab,
>> uh you want to just come over here.
>> Oh, yeah, sure.
>> All good. I'm stepping in. Uh yeah. So,
if you want to know about the
documentation of what these mean, you
can click on here uh to understand what
these fields represent. Um
>> they're also in line in the schema
itself.
>> Mhm.
Right.
>> And then you click on details.
>> Oh, maybe schema. You're right. Maybe
maybe the documentation is the best
place to go.
>> Mhm. Uh but yeah, let's say uh you
wanted to filter through. Um so this one
says registration per day.
So,
>> so those are the number of agents that
registered themselves as an agent using
the identity registry.
>> Correct. We're just going to let it run
for example. So now we have like a row
of the number of new agents that have
been registered. So given that this uh
ERC was made back at you know uh was
released back in January of uh 29,
there's obviously a lot of new agents
that got registered here. Um and we can
see through here. Uh, another really
good one to check out is um the second
one decoding a registered event.
So if we go here
and um also all of these queries uh you
don't have to take a picture of this but
all of these queries can be found here
in this gist with comments explaining um
>> from the prize page.
>> From the prize page. Yep. Um, but going
over here. So, this one shows a row of
like agent ID, the owner of that ID, uh,
and then the agent URI. Um, so the agent
URI can either be like a file, uh, like
file length of where a directory of
where it's pointed to, or it can also be
B 64 typically if it's onchain. So, um,
yep, we can do that. Uh, I think it'd be
fun to do a B 64 one, just a random one.
Go for it.
>> Yeah. Um, and another way to also look
at this too actually is if you go to uh
the
uh contracts, right? We have one for Oh,
this is the ETH global page.
>> Oh, we'll get that fixed. ERC80004
GitHub. Yep.
And we can click on, you know, obviously
we've got a bunch of data sets, but the
we want one we want to focus on is the
Ethereum mainet for identity and
registries, which is what Nolan was
talking about. Um, and you can actually
see like the uh identity contract. And
one thing you can do is you can click on
these transaction hash, look at for more
details, and actually like be able to
decode some of the input data. So maybe
we could do view through decoder.
and kind of see like oh okay this is a
agent ID and this is sort of the string
that's associated with that. So that's
another way of looking at it as well
too. Um
uh let's see another way another query
you can do is reputational leaderboard.
So I'll let
>> So this is the other smart contract that
manages reputation.
>> Mhm.
So we'll see that. Yep. So we have an
agent ID and then we have the feedback
count associated with it along with the
unique clients and like the average
score associated with them um for
validity purp you know for ranking
purposes. Um and then the last query
that would be good to know is
uh x42 join.
So I will raw
>> do the raw
and hit run.
Yep. And this will show us the agent ID
associated with the agent URI, the
average score associated with it. Um but
ideally also whether it's onchain,
offchain, and whether it's X4 or 2
supported. So you can actually filter um
whether it's true or false whe whether
an agent has X42 support or not. So if I
have to send it,
>> so there's like three values, null,
true, and false.
>> Yeah. So um but yeah, these are some
pretty useful queries to find um which
we have saved on here.
>> And if you need help with any of these,
we're at the booth. You can come and
talk to us. We can walk you through
these.
>> Um see, I think there's a few other
things here. Um just a little bit more
details on the prize. Thanks, Gotham.
Um, it's $5,000 cash, not credits on
Google Cloud or anything. You actually
get dollars. Um, and we're looking for,
you know, applications that leverage the
data set. Um, the ones that like, you
know, leverage like the reputation data
as well as the identity um from from the
from the smart contract. So like pulling
that data out and then some sort of
front end on top of it. That's not
required, but um it's always nice to
visualize those things. So maybe like an
explorer is one example, analytics um to
see like you know what's happening over
time, different ways to slice and dice
that data. Um and then you know more
information about which ones support X42
and what they're doing, right? Then you
can once you know it supports X42, then
you can do more downstream queries and
figure out how many transactions they've
done and the volumes there. Um and so
those are just some of the ideas, but
you can really build anything you want.
Um, you know, I think, uh, I'll be there
on Sunday morning judging. So, excited
to see what you guys are building. And
if you want to brainstorm some things,
uh, I'm at the booth. We'll open it up
to some questions. Uh, let me see if
there's anything else here. There's a
bunch of resources here. Um, I think
most of these are linked from the prize
page on the portal uh, inside the ETH
global, you know, portal. So, check it
out and, uh, if you have any questions,
let me know. I'm happy to answer
questions right now. Yeah, go ahead.
>> Thank you for building 804.
>> You're welcome.
>> What are your plans?
>> I don't think there's a plan to monetize
80004, right? It's meant to be an open
registry. Um, we want agents
to get adoption. We want more agents
being built. We feel like probably
you'll use some form of Gemini if you
build agents or maybe you'll host them
on Google Cloud, right? So, that's our
goal. Um but there's no direct
monetization plan here.
>> Um there aren't currently
official data sets for for base and
currently correct.
>> I believe there are. Yeah, the question
was are there official data sets for
bass and BNB. Um let me just check the
um 804 GitHub.
I know the vertical is supposed to
>> Oh, got you. Um, I think we have base
available as a data set. Um, if you
don't see it, come let me know and I
I'll help you there. Okay. Um, I'm not
sure about BNB. That's a good question.
But I believe we have base.
>> Yes.
what is 8,04
>> so I think what the the payload which
you register with
is like the name the description and
then the key things are the service
endpoints right so if you sell tell me
like oh you're this agent one I can
verify that you are the owner of that
agent because um that's a reg that's a
part of the registration event right it
gets emitted is the owner's wallet
address and the agent ID, then I can
look up what the the service URLs are
and I can make calls to those service
URLs.
>> Does that make sense?
>> Okay. Well, let's talk about it after
maybe at the booth.
>> Yes.
>> Yeah.
patterns.
>> No, we haven't had anybody build a cool
analytics uh explorer. So, that's that's
the job.
That's what we're paying $5,000 for.
>> Yes.
>> Yeah. So the idea is if you're
interacting with an agent that's
registered I think there's a dependency
that it's registered in the identity
registry then you can go ahead and leave
feedback for it based on your experience
with it so other people can leverage
that right the reputation right now like
we have some examples that people are
using like stars and latency and things
like that but really you can you leave
feedback on any facet like we've left
that open-ended so depending on what
that agent does it might be interesting
to leave feedback on different aspect
aspects of it and so we intentionally
left that open. Um but we think you know
over time there'll be like certain
things that people use um and more
standardization around that. Maybe the
standard evolves itself to like
accommodate the mainstream use cases.
It's just so early right now like it's
hard to know what to what to make as the
values.
>> No, we're not we're not um breaking up
the the judging or the criteria based on
verticals, but you're more than welcome
to do that. Um, if you want to find like
categorize and index all of the agents
based on their descriptions, I think
that'd be a really cool thing to do.
Yeah, I think right now I don't know if
there's a good answer to that.
Technically, anybody can leave uh
feedback. Um, so I don't think that part
has been solved. I think that's maybe
leads into some that third piece that
hasn't been figured out yet, which is
actually the validation of what work was
actually done, right? And then the
combination of those two things can
actually lead to a stronger signal.
>> Um, one thing you could technically do
is if there are unique identifier
fields, like filter for once, so if you
know if there's like a repeating actor
that's just like potentially spammy, you
could like filter by that as a way.
>> Yeah.
>> Any other questions?
>> Yes.
the the part of the vision is to index
agents behavior and the future of what
happens in AI.
Are there behaviors outside of agents in
the cluster of AI or is it mostly agent?
>> That's a good question. Um, I think this
particular spec was built with agents in
mind, but you make a good point that the
scope of AI and reputation probably goes
beyond agents. Um, so yeah, maybe
that's, you know, feel free to
contribute to the spec.
We can we we know the right people to
talk to.
Any other questions?
Awesome.
Well, you know, uh, Amelia's in the back
there. She'll be working on the booth
and can help you get coupon codes. I can
help you get coupon codes. So, come talk
to us. One more question over here.
>> Oh, yeah. I'm just curious about how you
guys think about.
>> I'm not sure I have a I'm not familiar
with what you're talking about, so I
probably shouldn't speak on it, but I'm
happy to talk about it at the booth.
>> Awesome, guys. Well, thanks for coming.
I hope you participate and uh looking
forward to what you guys build.